okay well it's great to see so many
familiar faces and so many new faces uh
today and at least you're smiling now so
that's a good sign too maybe I can give
a good talk
uh a lot of you are are might be
wondering about these books that are
strewn on the floor in the front this is
this is part of a a a Christmas
tradition uh
every all through the year I I keep
getting uh copies of my books that are
uh like they they a new printing came
out and and so they give me a book so
that I can check it or or or or um a new
translation came out and they send me
two copies of the translation and I I
only need one and and so uh I bring the
extra copies with me and they're and
they're sitting here uh this year so
some some of them are in uh in Chinese
Japanese uh most of them are in English
uh and and there's also a couple of of
of real collector's items uh Tech
reports from from the from the
uh from when metap was new uh and things
like that so anyway I have multiple
copies of of stuff and this is this is
my way to to do to do better than than
put it in the in the recycle bin
um I'm going to sit down in a minute oh
yeah there's a rule though
uh first of all only one to a customer
um so you know if if you need two of
them you and your friend each get
one uh and and the other one is uh
uh if you ask a specific a particularly
good question during the talk uh then
I'm going to mention that that that you
get First Choice before somebody else uh
uh because other otherwise you know you
might come up but you only get one of
the of the ones that you didn't want to
read anyway so so uh uh but but anyway
uh so those are the ground rules one to
customer and and then there's going to
if anybody does ask a good question uh
uh then they get priority um and uh and
and by the way that means that you are
allowed to ask
questions as I talk okay now I'm going
to sit down because I'm an old man um
I've got a lot to I've got a lot to say
uh and I I hope I can get it all out in
in the right order when I was a grad
student uh hey we got people standing in
the back there there are some there are
some empty seats in the
front uh all not not a heck of a lot of
them I
guess so so when I was a grad student my
adviser Marshall Hall was the world's
foremost foremost authority on
permutations
and I took his class and I didn't really
understand his lectures that well but I
wrote down everything he said and and
then the the problem was to find a
permutation of his words that would make
sense afterwards uh well I'm going to
try to give the right permutation today
but if I don't well you might have to
watch the video and and and replay it um
the uh uh title as you get as you uh can
see where at the bottom is is dancing
cells and as Pax mentioned the uh uh my
talk five years ago uh was called
dancing links and also in the year 2000
I uh when when the whole thing was was
kind of brand new I I also had a I'm
using on YouTube called dancing links
and uh yeah I I I watched them and I'm
still not too embarrassed about what I
said then but but but but uh actually
there's a lot of good news uh uh because
we've improved dancing link now to to
something that has the Jazzy name
dancing cells and and uh uh but the uh
basically the uh this this talk is about
data structures and and so were the two
talks before that were called dancing
leaks in other words uh the way to
represent information in a computer uh
and the
structure the the structure between uh
between items of data uh uh is is called
the structures problem and and in the um
uh uh oldtimers like me and our hoopus
we used to think that all the important
data structures were were well
understood by 1970 or 1980 uh so so no
need to learn anything more but uh but
what I'm talking today is something that
I I I learned you know three years ago
and and I I could have learned 10 years
ago if I was if I looked the right place
uh so so um
uh and I I'll get into the detail but
the whole story starts with one of the
one of the first really uh really great
great books of computer science I don't
know if anybody you always remember this
one AO hopcraft and
Alman hands anybody know this book
here's one few yeah okay yeah we
could 5% so so this book came out uh uh
almost exactly 50 years ago um and uh
and it had this exercise on page 71 I
think it
was
um so see if we can zoom in to right to
right
here
is uh okay so it's it exercise
2.2 and it has asterisk means Advanced
uh and and and this said develop a
technique to initialize an entry of a
matrix to zero the first time it is
accessed thereby eliminating the order
v^ 2 time to initiate to initialize an
adjacency Matrix of a graph and then it
gives a hint as to as to as to how to do
that uh and and this exercise I mean in
my copy of the book uh in the back cover
I I I noticed you know pages that really
surprised me and this and the first one
was exercise 212 uninitialized memory
well and so so what's that all about um
well let's let's suppose we have a a a
uh a huge array in memory
um uh and in those days um a huge array
meant more than a thousand or more than
10,000 but but but now you could just
imagine we have have some array that
that has you
know a few billion elements or something
like that um and it's all full it's all
filled with uh uh with with uh something
random bits basically we don't we don't
have any idea what's in it but we would
still like to use the computer's ability
to to do random access so so we want to
access something and and so we want to
we we want to work it out so that uh
if I I want to store things in this
memory without initializing it so so so
the first time I uh
you so so maybe uh uh
uh here's element 3142 for example and
and and I I want to store something in
in in uh position
3142 uh so I I want this to be reliable
but I don't want to have to spend the
time to I want it to act as if it was
all initialized to zero but but I don't
want to take the time to actually do the
initialization without you know that
that might be take longer than my whole
program so so uh uh what's what's the
secret and and so the secret is uh okay
so well we can call this uh uh sparse I
guess um and then I have another U
another array over here called dense um
and and um
uh so so
what happens is I I I I look at this
element whatever it is uh uh
and and if it and and I know how many
elements I've already seen so so do I
have another another counter s say s is
the
size how many things initially there's
nothing in D and initially s is zero uh
so so
uh
what I'm going to do is I'm going to put
I'm going to put zero here and I'm going
to put 3142
here in position zero of then and then
and then okay now uh and since and since
s was Zero uh uh no matter what I
fetched here uh uh I know it'll be the
first time well I mean maybe next thing
I I I put something here in position
1618 and and and so I can put a one
there and I put 161 18 here and and then
uh uh do more computation and and say
okay now let me look at 3142 well I I
look at 40 3142 it has the number zero
in it I check zero oh yeah that's that
that that matches so that's good uh so
so now I uh do some more calculation
what's another number I might want to do
here 2718 or something like this I might
I might want to probe 20 2718 and I
and I look in 201718 oh I see uh uh
there's a one in there um but I look in
position one and it doesn't say 2718 so
so so that didn't work so so I know that
I've got to put two here and I've now
got two I've now got two items so so so
the uh main idea is then uh I have I I
can use all these guys and and whenever
I what whatever I read there's going to
be something in there and I'm going to
reject that unless it unless it points
to something less than S and and and the
the dense array confirms that it's it
was actually something that I did to the
okay so so this is the trick and uh it's
called the the U uh uh it got to be
called the sparse uh the sparse array
trick so sometime during the
uh sometime during the 80s I got around
to to revising my book the art of
computer programming volume one and and
uh
U the Third Edition didn't come out
until 25 years ago but uh but but at
that time we did I I did have the
exercise on page 307 here uh called the
sparse array trick so suppose you want
to use a large array for Random Access
although you won't actually being
referred to very many of its entries you
want AFK to be zero the first time you
exit but you don't want to spend the
time to set every location to zero
explain how it's possible to read and
write any desired elements AFK WR
reliably given K without assuming
anything about the actual initial memory
contents doing only a small fixed number
of additional operations per array axis
I got a question back here yeah yeah
maybe a basic question in your example
let's say you know at the next step I
want to write zero to location
999 999 yeah what would I
do okay now in in location 999 yes all
right
so here it is and and I look at
999 and and I Fetch and I fetch what
whatever is in there okay not not now
what whatever is in
there if it's bigger than if it's bigger
than two then it's got to be bad if it's
less than two I can check to see if it's
okay okay so I let me write down the uh
write down the algorithm um
so so let's say
read um re read K okay what does that
mean so so I so I set R set R to sparse
of
K all right and then I say
if
R less than
S
and dense
of
R can you read that equals
k um
return uh uh data of I I I'm going to
have another I I'm going to have another
uh another array data here where where I
actually actually actually put uh
actually put stuff um so so return
return data of okay um you know
otherwise uh I set sparse
of sparse of K to
S um and dense of s to
K
and I'm also going to put back of I keep
keep another array back in case somebody
wants me to restore memory to the way it
was before this not necessary but it
maybe maybe they want it so back of s to
r s um to S + one and return zero and so
this is an integer uh sube K and so it
it return zero the first time something
comes and and so so income 999 uh
whatever it is it's uh it's not going to
pass this test and so we're going to set
uh uh sparse of
uh I'm 999 K is 999 so we're going to
said sparse of 999 to S which is three
uh and then we're going to set dense of
s to K which
is which is
here um and we're going to set back of s
to to uh whatever whatever that that
that number was in there X
x999 and so and then s is now is now
equal to four um okay so thanks for the
question
now uh and and of course that's what the
uh that's what the answer
uh one of the things about about my book
is it does have answers and uh and so in
the answer it's it mentioned it mentions
that by the way you you could also uh
back up to the original to the original
condition if you wanted to okay now um
uh that was 50 years ago
um something else happened uh 25 years
ago and that was a paper that that came
out
um so this is
1993 a paper that that came out by
Preston Briggs and Linda torson at at
rice and and they're working on
compilers and they had they had I
developed uh an
extension of these ideas that turned out
to be important u in in their compiler
implementation and and and so here it
says uh uh inspired by a memorable
homework problem of AO at
all problem 2.12 we developed a sparse
set representation that supports all the
required operations efficiently and we
have okay so uh
uh in other words homework problems
actually do uh get noticed somehow by
and and and so somehow you know people
were were getting the idea and they but
their application was different they
they didn't really they weren't really
faced with a billion word array that
they wanted they didn't want to
initialize they really wanted to to
represent just just a subset of of a
universe and and and so they weren't
interested in what what's in this
billion word already they just they're
just interested in which which parts of
the array have we actually uh used so
far uh so so words they didn't they
didn't need the data part here or uh
they only wanted to know
uh this list
here of the dent stuff so so um at uh
but but
uh they they um they gave it basically
the algorithm that I just wrote down
except that we didn't have to store
anything or return zero um and then they
did something new because their Caper
needed it and that is on the next page
they had a delete operation now deletion
is something that a hopc noan did not
talk about and neither did I uh and and
so they so they said well uh we we can
also uh
uh we can also remove stuff that that
that that was you know so so let me
uh
uh skip to
uh uh well well actually
um I'm searching for the right
permutation here uh uh so so let me skip
now
to the book that I published last year
uh and uh this is Art of Compu daada art
of computer programming volume 4B it uh
it makes a wonderful Christmas present
and and it uh uh I I I just learned
today that the uh that the Japanese
translation has been finished and will
be published in two weeks and so so the
Korean and Chinese translations
are are going to be second and third in
this in this race but okay so now uh uh
I think uh
let's see where am I on page 40 page 40
here so so here I'm talking about
commentator algorithms and how to how to
represent uh uh sets of things when you
want to undo your operation is will do
things so so so so when resolving
combinatory problems
uh it it's basically uh we want to uh
we're searching for
uh a lot of needles in a huge hay stack
and and so so so we look at
parts of the
uh of the tree of possibilities and uh
and and we have sets sets of
possibilities that that grow uh and
Shrink uh but but but but they start out
with lots of possibilities that
then that that we n narrow down the
possibilties after a while uh but but
after we've explored that part then we
have to to go back uh uh to a larger set
again so so in these applications uh we
start with a set that contains the whole
universe instead of instead of the uh
aill so on which started with a set of
that was empty uh now we're starting
with with the entire set and and and we
delete stuff periodically and this is
something that
uh that Briggs and toan did
that
that wasn't done before they they
deleted instead of inserted and uh so so
here's here's the idea um uh let's
suppose that we have a set with with
with four things in it I got three 3 n
one and four and uh uh so so so K the
said it's it's just listed sequentially
but in another array we've got the we've
got pointers to this one so so three I
one points to to where one is stored
three points to where three is stored
nine points to where nine is stored and
four points to where four is stored it's
it's it's like the uh uh this sparse uh
I this dense array that that we had
before uh sparse and dense I mean the
bottom one is sparse and the top one is
the dense version and so now let's
suppose we want to to delete
nine so so if if if we delete
nine
um we can see where nine is um but we we
can swap
nine with the
four so move the nine over here and
bring the four to to where the nine was
and then just
move move the tail back so so you you
can see see by deleting we we sort of do
a swap in there and uh
uh everything
works Zip Zip
Zip uh so
so that's the I that's the idea of
deletion and I'm I'm going to work
out an example uh in some details in
order to make it clear I hope um
so in this application uh then I've got
a a
uh a a a universe of of possibilities um
and I I I want to at every point I I
want to be be
representing some subset of that
universe and and and and people who work
in in the commentor algorithms they call
it they call it the domain so so give
have an example where the domain has
five elements so so so I have
Dom uh is an array that has a
uh
five entries and and I also have another
another array I'll call it
idam and and and each of these contains
a permutation of of of the
U of the possible elements of the domain
so here here I'm consider considering
that a domain is is some subset of 0 1 2
3 4
and uh uh and I've got all these numbers
here and I hav told you what they mean
so this is Dom of zero this is Dom of
one this is Dom of two this is these are
the identity permutation so so it just
happens that that that we start out
everything Dom of zero is zero Dom of
one is one and and and and so on and
then I have S which is the total the
total size of the domain which is five
um and I can so now let's suppose I
delete
um uh I delete
one so so that means I can swap one with
four and bring the four over
here that's that's Dom now well I is the
inverse permutation well it turns out
the inverse of this permutation is is
the same but U the
the examples will become clear soon but
but but but now s equals 4 so indicate
that by putting a vertical line
say at position s u now in order to make
it a little more clear uh let's let's
try to delete four now so
um at this point uh I'm going to I'm
going to switch the four with the
three and S is going to go down to three
and and U and the inverse
permutation well so zero is still in
position zero four is now in position
three two is still in position two three
is in position one and and one and four
is in position three whoops one is in
position
four so so this is the inverse inverse
permutation um so so I so in other words
uh the first s elements of Dom these are
the elements of our
set u and then the other elements that
aren't in our set are listed
afterwards it's a permutation so so then
I say well where does zero appear zero
appears right in position zero where
does one appear it occurs in position
four where does two appear three appear
and so so on so so so if I want to test
test whether something is is in the if I
want to test whether four is in the set
I I I look at
idam of four which is
three and it's not in the set because
it's bigger than or equal to S so now so
I I'll do another example and then and
then write down the
algorithm pretty soon you you'll see why
it's very simple so if I delete two all
I have to do is is move is move that
line one space to the left because I I
don't have to swap anything
um okay delete
zero delete zero I'm going to have to
switch three
zero s is s is now
one and uh so so zero is in position one
one is in position four two is in here
three is z four is
three all right now so so that's
the that's the idea
uh but the beauty that the beautiful
thing is
undelete suppose I say
undelete uh
zero
I I can do that by just by just shifting
by just changing as shifting this to
this to the
right I don't get back to the if I
undelete zero I'm sitting here with 03
um and but but now s is two I I'm not I
I'm not back at what I had
before I'm sorry this is 30 I I I I I
don't change anything except the the POS
s and so I don't change anything except
the cut off and so so so um I've got I
I've got the same set set I had here but
it's not it's not exactly the same
representation because every every
subset has many
representations um and that and and so
the beauty is untion is it is Trivial uh
I mean just change that so if I want to
undelete zero two and four I can I can
undo all of these three three things I
don't change anything except change S
back to
four and here it's going to be 3024 so
so you see uh the the the the numbers to
the right of this bar show the things
that I took out in the order that I took
them out if I move the bar I get back to
where I I get back to the same set of
elements I had
before the set of elements doesn't
appear in any particular order and I I
could have started this whole process uh
uh with 0 1 2 3 4 I'm sorry I could have
start started this whole process with
3241 uh and 1 14 two or3 any any any
permutation in its inverse I I could
have St that and say that's my
representation of of the entire
domain so dancing so so as the algorithm
proceedes these these numbers in here
I do little dance and the importance of
this was was first recognized 10 years
ago in in this paper uh that came out
that this is
2013 uh sparse sets for domain implement
ation and um uh I I really want to meet
this guy because he's got the most
interesting name I've ever I've ever
V and then
Pi
Christine she's my friend who told me
about this paper and and Christa Lut uh
who wrot one of the one of the main
books on on uh constraint satisfaction
uh and so these people are in U uh in
Belgium and France and and they noticed
uh that the
um that that this this idea that that
had had had come up in
connection with h Spar sets uh 20 sorry
um 30 30 years ago uh
uh
I what actually happened was I think
they discovered it independently and
then they were showing to people and say
oh yeah this is the same as what people
were calling Spar sets uh uh so so U uh
I I write out the algorithm and we can
see what it uh what it means so
delete
k um says Uh set R to I of
K uh in other words I want to delete
element K so I I say where is where
where does K sit in the Dom array so I
Dom of K tells me where K appears uh
then it says if R is greater than or
equal to S uh return because it's not in
it's not in the domain if if if it's
sitting if if if uh R is to the right of
that line it's it's not in the correct
domain so so we can't delete it uh
otherwise s is s- one and and we look at
uh D of s so so so we look at the guy
who's in in the position
now that is
uh that's going to be leaving us uh and
and we change D of R to L and and I of L
to R because this this preserves the
inverse
permutation um and then we also
uh keep track of of of what's going on
for the larger elements I of
l r oops D of D of
s is um K and I of K is
say so you you can check that that's
what I did in
this u in now that's dancing cells let
me let me show you what it was what it
was like with dancing
links
um so so dancing links was intended to
solve the same kind of problem where we
want to keep track of domains and
dancing links uh uh we started out with
all all all five
possibilities and these were kept in in
little nodes in the computer and and and
and and they were pointing to each other
with a doubly linked list
um well I I actually put a h i put a
header note in here uh so so so
everything pointed to the guy in front
and and the guy after um and
um
uh so
so so there's a header
node and then after the header node this
guy this points to this this point to
this this point to this now when I
deleted
one uh uh in this case uh what happens
well we still got the heter node um uh
and zero is here but zero doesn't point
to one anymore zero points over to
two um and two points back to zero now
but we but we still have the doubly link
list connecting okay and and uh uh uh
I'll delete one I'll do one more
deletion this is the way dancing links
work um
uh so if I deleted four then three is
now going to point off off here uh and
uh and this guy's going to point back
not to four but to three and and the and
these two points to
three and sorry Zer points to two two
points to okay and and uh the the
uh
U the
idea when when we were doing dancing
links the idea was
um
to was he to to be unclean to be sloppy
not to clean up our act so so after one
was deleted one one still is pointing to
two and and as its sucessor and is still
pointing to zero as its predecessor and
and after four was deleted four is still
pointing here so so that when I want to
do an undelete I it's easy to do an
undelete because because I know exactly
which pointers I have to change when I'm
UND deleting and that was that was the
idea of dancing links
uh with with uh uh with dancing cells
the untion is even is even faster
because all we because I don't have to
CH I only have to change uh uh one
number to undo a whole a whole set of
deletion okay so so this is uh the
difference between dancing links and
dancing cells U and uh in both cases
we're sort of uh uh using okay both
cases first of all are extremely simple
the algorithms are only a few lines long
secondly uh uh it was we almost did in
the 60s we almost did this but in the
60s I I didn't do dancing links because
I because after I deleted something I
also I also was afraid to have these
other uh excess pointers sitting around
there so so I so so I zered them out uh
and I found out that if I didn't zero it
out uh uh it wasn't going to be garbage
collected and and I was going to be able
to uh uh to do to do everything Zip Zip
later on so with the dancing cells uh uh
the new idea is that uh
uh we we keep track what's going on to
to the right of of the bar the the
elements bigger than S in the array of
we don't ignore those we keep them up to
date we we keep an inverse per
permutation going all the time and we're
uh and then we're in good shape okay so
so so now U I'm going to uh uh go
and
uh and show you more exactly what what's
happening but first some question that I
can answer yeah way in the
back that yeah well you it's you yeah um
sir
I'm wondering whether for like other set
operations like unions and intersections
if you're for unions and intersections
if you're willing to do them in place
I'm sorry I can't hear you I do um I
I'll yell louder uh for unions and
intersections if you're willing to do
them Union and intersection yeah yeah
can you can you get those pretty
efficiently if you're willing to do them
in place it's possible to do Union and
intersection but I but but the
application I'm talking about we don't
care okay
yeah the the uh compliment no but
difference yes wait for a compliment you
could just store the take compliment you
have you with the respect to the
universe that's um I I guess you you
could you just the dire your way around
yeah yeah that's a good point yeah no
that's true uh the
compliment Briggs and ton didn't know
how to do compliment but but now we do
do because we have the in this right
yeah okay uh what if like let's say you
had you wanted to I still can't hear you
s okay uh let's say that you wanted to
make like a positive set instead of so
you initially delete everything from
your set but you do it in the or like
basically the reverse frequency order so
if you think that you're set start again
okay let's say you started with
everything and then you delete elements
in a particular order yeah based on like
their inverse frequency so if an element
is very likely to appear or be added to
your set then you want to delete that
last right because then the undelete
operation be very quick I have some
other process
controlling telling me what to delete
yeah but the data here I'm talking
about you whatever that her istic
is this is the internal
representation
okay but so I I can build other things
around this yeah okay
yeah right not back here yeah I'm while
I'm back here
wow back row yeah if you want to delete
if you delete ABC and then undelete B
yeah you swapping
right it's always last and first out
okay yeah no there's a way
to that's called insertion
yeah right
so yeah so I'm glad for these questions
be uh and uh the people who ask
questions by the way have priority for
the books so so uh now
uh now I want to talk about the context
of of of this whole thing so so so why
am I interested in domains and what you
know so uh the general context is uh
solving commentator problems and and by
that I mean by commentator problem I uh
I I I sort of mean find all Arrangements
of
objects very general sense and so so uh
uh combinatorial problem is is somehow
arrangements and I know three good ways
to uh uh to to define a common a
commodor problem uh so good good way
um
to to
Define
u interesting class of Arrangements um
uh and and good by by good I mean uh
declarative I I I mean
I I don't I I I want to I I want to say
what the arrangements are without
without giving the method that I'm going
to have to to do it but but defining
this this means to formalize you
know to to make a
model some kind of you know encoding of
of of the problem explaining exactly
what it means so
so so I know I know three good ways to
uh uh to encode or or make a model of of
of comor problems in in a way that's
declarative instead of imperative I
declare what the problem is and let the
computer figure out how to solve it and
and and uh uh uh one of the main ones
each of these has has a three-letter
pneumonic and constraint satisfaction
problem is one of them um is one of
these
pneumonics and uh uh that's what CSP
stands for and this means that we have
that our model has variables and each
variable has a domain and then we have
and then uh we have uh
uh constraints which are relations
between between the values of the
variable uh that's first this next one
called sat this is for
satisfiability um
and this is the special case of CSP when
all the domains are just Boolean every
variable has just two Val two possib
values well the CSP allows uh you know
diary U things in fact it also allows
continuous and infinite domain but I but
but that's Way Beyond me I I I'm a
finite guy um and and and the Third Way
is is xcc which is um exact covering
with
colors uh now um
xcc I didn't write I didn't write it
very xcc is is the new kit on the Block
it isn't as well known as the other two
in
fact as of today it still doesn't have a
Wikipedia page uh I think that something
else
entirely if you if you do Google for xcc
which is a shame because because uh half
of of my book volume four is about xcc
so so so so I'm waiting for people to uh
to realize that what a great uh uh what
a great thing this is but anyway I I
don't have I I don't have time to wait I
have to write more books but but but U
and I'm you
know I might give one more lecture
trying to popularize but anyway sooner
or later people will realize that that
that that xcc
is is a really important idea and and
each of these is sort of equal powerful
I can take any CSP and I can I can I can
encode it I can convert it to a SAT
problem several ways I can I can convert
it to an xcc problem in several ways and
and similarly xcc problem I can
represent in s i can represent as a CSP
whatever but but uh uh each uh each each
come to a problem you some of them are
best as sat some of them are best xcc
some are best as CSP and the U uh and
and the purpose of this let me just show
show you uh I've got 450
exercises in here that that give uh uh
examples of why you'd want to know
something why XC is is a great model um
and so let's see the exercises start
here so we I just page you start paging
through if if
if zoom out a little bit you you can see
there from the pictures that there's a
lot of variety of the of of the kind of
of problems you have that that that
we're modeling with h with xcc problem
and uh uh let's see like I said 450 so
we
got so these are are lots of different
kinds of problem uh and
uh this is only the tip of the iceberg
it ends with
uh with
puzzles okay so
um that's the context why I'm interested
in dancing cells I
want
I you know we got CSP solvers we got sat
solvers and we got xcc solvers and up
until uh up until last year uh the the
uh the best xcc solver was was called
DLX or dlx2 anyway and and DL stood for
dancing
links and
uh and so we had
uh for more than 20 years the the method
of choice if you had xcc problem DX was
was doing very well and and and you know
people would would have petitions with
with same problems try to solve them as
CSP sat and and DLX was winning um uh so
there's a lot of there were a lot of
problems for for which dancing links was
uh the go- through method but uh
uh Christine solo who I mentioned uh a
few minutes ago uh introduced me to this
idea
of the name dancing cells by the way is
is her is her idea too um and she IND
introduced me to to this other data
structure U instead of using dou link
list I could use I could use two arrays
permutation and inverse permutation and
so let me show show you now
uh what is an xcc problem and and how do
we actually implement it with with
dancing cells so I'm going to give you a
toy ex uh
a toic problem just so you get the
idea and EXC as I said is exact covering
with colors U it's um it's based on
so-called options and
items so so when you want when we want
to to to state an xcc problem uh uh we
give a list of all the options that are
available to to us and we when we're
supposed to choose uh the best options
in some or or choose all all compatible
options um and so an option uh option is
is is a set of
items um uh uh so well for example uh
you know we're trying to find
Arrangement so so maybe it's a schedule
for for classes that or for final exams
that's that for maybe we maybe we're
trying to assign PE people to jobs and
and so then an option would be you know
assign uh Jo Joe to to run the camera U
uh uh the items are are are the uh uh
like Joe it would be an item and and a
and a camera um and and and the items
are are are either primary or or or
secondary so so we have a primary item
um and a secondary item um and
uh the the
name the name xcc say exact covering
with colors um
the the differ a a primary item uh so
okay
so you list your options and your
problem is uh to
choose to choose among these options so
that every P primary item is covered
exactly once so there's exactly one
chosen
option for for every item so if I'm
trying to match people to jobs then
every person gets a job and every job
has been assigned a person if if I'm uh
okay so so then the secondary item
uh however uh it has has a color a
secondary item
has it sign the color and and in your
options
uh for a secondary item uh you don't
have to have that secondary item doesn't
have to be in any of the options but but
whatever options it does appear it has
to always have the same color so so so
so
uh so the primary option says uh uh you
know this this is the option that uses
that uses me
the secondary option says these are the
flavors of in which I can appear so so
you think of a cross word puzzle where
the um the primary items are the words
across and
down secondary items are the letters
that are that are entered and so so if
if if one of your
options puts the letter X in a
particular cell another another option
uh for the downward has to put an X in
that cell in that same cell so the
secondary the x is the color of the
things so so primary items and secondary
items appearing options and that's the
idea of exact covering cover I'm give
you a very a very simple toy problem now
let make it all all crystal clear um so
so I'm I'm going to say there are there
are five items p p q and R and X and Y
uh these are
primary and these are
secondary and the op and and I'm going
to going to give you
options Alpha Beta Gamma Delta Epsilon
are five options the first option
is
p
q x c y a Okay so
so option Alpha says take P cover P
cover
Q uh give X color C give y color a beta
is p r x colored a y colored
C
uh uh gamma is says take P all by itself
and X color B Delta says take q and x
colored a and Epsilon says take R and Y
color B so so let's see if we can solve
this problem oh I've got to choose I've
got to choose options uh so that P is
covered exactly once Q is covered
exactly once R is covered exactly once
and X is is colored the same in uh in
all the choices and Y is colored the
same in all the choices so so for
example suppose I
uh suppose I choose option Alpha okay so
so so that says I I I've covered p and Q
so I so I I can't cover I can't cover
beta because I've already got
P I can't cover gamma because I've
already covered p and I can't cover
Delta because I've already covered Q so
I so so if I've chosen Alpha then then
the only way I can cover R is is to
choose Epsilon but that says Y is
colored B and Y has already been colored
a so I so Alpha is
out there could be no way to solve this
with Alpha well let's suppose Alpha is
out then now now there's only one one
way left to cover Q so I so I've got to
use
Delta so I I've covered q and I and I
decided X is
a and and so so so that that throws out
gamma because X is B here so so so I've
got to um uh the only way left to cover
p is it is is to use beta and so the the
answer is the answer is going to be that
that the I have to choose these three
options beta Delta and Epsilon in order
in order to in order to do this all
right what
why not Epsilon
not Epsilon just this hey I'm yeah I i'
like to claim that I did this on purpose
to see if
anybody but but but in fact I I blew it
okay so yeah yeah all right now so so
the the but the U uh
uh the key thing to realize as we're
solving this problem is that that uh we
start with with the whole problem but
every time we make a decision we get a
sub problem which is another CC problem
that's simpler than the one we started
with so so so for so so if I if for
example if I say that that I choose
Alpha then then it tells me to eliminate
all the
other you know because I've already
covered P it tells me eliminate this
eliminate this eliminate this and and so
we found out that the sub problem was we
were left with uh with with r still to
be covered but no options and that was a
problem that that has no solution so now
we go back and we and now we say oh okay
I can't use Alpha so so let's consider
the problem that doesn't have Alpha so
so I throw Alpha out and and if I throw
Alpha out
uh uh well that that just delete that
just deletes
that that just deletes that line U
okay okay so this is the toy problem let
me now show show you how we how we do it
inside the computer how am I going to
actually write an algorithm that that
represents this uh
uh the old
U so so I had the same
problem
um oh turn on page 89 of volume 4B it
turned out the same toy problem uh was
here and and and I showed how it was
represented w w with doubly link list I
mean each each
uh each thing had a PO or two uh uh uh
to to its neighbors um in in this in
this data
structure let's do it now however with
um uh with dancing cell so so here not
okay now pay
attention look look close here I I'm
going to have um I'm going to have one
array
that that that lists all the options and
I'm going to call this array of nodes
and and so I'm going to have node X
um node x uh and and I'm going to have
nodes I'm going to number the nodes xal
0 1 2 3 four and and I uh uh I'll see
how many I need uh and and
then node X well actually
it it's not a note is going to have
three parts to it and and and and so I'm
first going to talk about the um
uh of the the item part of X of and then
and then the color part of
X and then there's something called the
Lo part of X so so node of X really has
has three components and uh so so here's
where here's where I list uh my my my
top problem so uh I got the uh uh item X
is going to be P
PQ
XY it's it's for it this is this is for
um Alpha here is is is is going to
appear here um U between between options
I I I I've got a I've got a spacer so so
there's going to be six seven I'm going
to put beta here um
and that's p
r
XY um and then U the spacer and Gamma is
going to be um p and uh and
x and that'll be 11 12 another spacer
here
Delta will be
QX and then Epsilon will be r
y
so this will be 14 15 16 17 18
19 the Epsilon here Delta here and this
and I got spaces here so the color is
where I put the colors so x x is color c
y is color a here x is color a y is
color c x is color b x is color a y is
color B so this is so so in my
um in this array of nodes I have I have
the data and but then I have to to for
the spacer in order in order to navigate
around here so so so I put
um uh after an option with four items I
I I put a minus four in the item
position and so this is going to be a
minus four and this is going to be a
minus two minus two and a minus two and
then be before it I I I put in the
um uh in the Lo position I I I'm putting
a plus4 here and
plus4 plus4 plus two so so so then uh as
as I'm walking around the data structure
I I can put a zero here U so I can use I
can use this part of of memory to to
know when I'm at the end of an option
and go from the end back to the
beginning if I want to um now
um
got
another I I I also have to remember for
each item which options it appears in so
so I have a big
uh another array which I call set and
and I'm going to show you a set of I and
I uh
and and this is this is going to be a a
interesting but but bear with me as I as
I write it
out uh so um I
is U goes 0 1 two 3 four and so on and
so on uh and and in and I'm going to
associate P item p with with location
two you you'll see why in a minute but
but
but uh
P if you see uh uh item P occurs three
times it occurs here in position one in
in six and and 11 so for my dancing cell
data structure I have to have the
inverse permutation so I have to so I
have to have one six and 11 uh
and uh
and and and the location is going to for
this is location P location p+ 1 and
location p+ 2 in other words one
is
uh the location of this in the set array
is is position two p position P location
of this in the set array is position P
plus one and here it's position so so so
U as I write this out you you'll
uh you'll get the idea I'm I'm going to
I'm going to put Q uh here uh I I I'm
reserving these these two cells for
other information that that's going to
be helpful associated with P in fact
here here I'm going to put size of
p and here I'm going to put some
something I call position of p uh just
just write size um so this is sorry this
is pause and this is size for for Q and
the size of of p is three because there
are three things in this set
so so one six and okay so so so Q
appears Q appears in in two and 14 so
there's two and 14
here U then I'm going to have R is
similar puse size and R is going to go
this is going to be 9 10 11 so R is
going to be number 11 and uh it it
appears in in seven and um
uh and and so on uh so
uh so so this is how I'm setting so
inside the computer I've got a my main
operation uh the domain of of each item
of each variable the variables are the
items so the domain are the options in
which uh the primary the options in
which they appear and so I've got to
know where where where the
uh which options contain contain p and
and and and by looking at the size I
know how many options are available for
uh for that guy uh so um
uh then there's another there's another
array item which uh which completes the
which completes the scheme and in item
there there are five items uh and and
one of them is is p qrx and
Y and I have
uh uh so so now I actually my
handwriting isn't isn't very good so
I so I uh printed this this all out and
I made the assignment that that that P
is equal to
uh know p is equal to two Q is equal to
7 R so on so the
so in the item array P QR X and Y inside
the computer it says 27 11 15 21 those
are the places where P QR X and Y are so
and x x is in a uh is in four of the
options uh position in 3 8 12 and 15 so
here it is three 8 12 and 15 those are
the ones that have item X the item equal
to to uh the letter X which is 15 uh and
then the location is 15 16 17 18 that's
where that's where x equal appears in
the set array so so we've got the the
the these
numbers
um this is a permutation of the places
where P where where P
appears um these are the
this is um this is Alpha
here this is
beta this is gamma this is Delta
Epsilon and
um uh so so 2 three
four two two three 234 is a permutation
of the placees where P
appeared the it's the um
uh the way everything appears compactly
in memory and uh
uh the C thing about dancing cells is
that uh
uh when you're debugging it you really
have to have to have special tools in
order to see what's going on because
everything is you know all all the
information is there but it's but but
it's not in the in the traditional way
that that that our parents taught us
okay so so um the uh I guess I uh each
um each thing uh each item has a
dedicated part of the set array um uh
and as the algorithm runs
U these
uh the item field of node color field of
node are always going to be fixed these
are constant they stay the same but but
as things go in and out of these domains
uh we're going to change we're going to
change the Lo parts and and we're also
going to change these numbers here so so
let me show you what happens when uh
when we decide that option Alpha is no
good so so at some point we come to the
conclusion that that we don't want uh we
don't want Alpha anymore in our problem
so so we're going to we're going to go
to a sub problem that doesn't have Alpha
and uh what does that mean that that
means we have to
delete uh we have to delete Alpha from
the from the sets it appears
in so we look at uh at the first item of
alpha it's it's item two in location two
so so here's item two uh and uh it has a
size of
three we want to delete delete one from
this set of three
element so that means I'm going to I'm
going to move 11 here and move one up
here and I'm going to change the size to
two from three to two that that's the
deletion operation on on this set I I
mean the set is
before I was I was I was drawing an
array left to right now I'm doing it top
to top down but but but but but by by
changing this
two by by changing set of two to to uh
from from one to 11 you
know I move these two guys around and
and then I say the size is now is now
two instead of three so it means the
options that now contain P are 11 and
six
U okay similarly I I
I'm I delete from Seven I can see that
this is I I this item is Q so its size
is going to go down to one and I'm and
I'm going to move U 14 here and two here
um uh uh
x x is is this guy so I got to delete
the three out of this set so this
becomes 15 this becomes three and now
the side
goes down from four to
three so X is now in these three options
and and and finally y
uh gets
change um and
uh
uh it's all a mess now so here's what
happened after I have purged Alpha from
the system uh I I I'm now left with
uh sizes
two I had here so
um
Alpha you know Alpha is still here in
the noes but the but but but but it's
invisible if we look in the sets uh uh
you know the set the set of P now has
only two things in it uh the set of Q
now has only one thing in it uh the set
of R still has two things in it the set
of x uh has three things in it and Y has
has two things in it so
um this represents now the sub problem
after I've deleted option
Alpha and uh stay with me for another
few minutes
uh and uh
uh because I'm I'm going to do one more
step so that
hopefully so now Q has only this one
option remaining it it's got to
be the size is one so Q only appears in
in this option here which
is which says 17 which says 14 here it
is is uh yeah so 14 this is this is
Delta and and and so uh I I have to
um now saying oh I'm going to choose
option
Delta so so so choosing option
Delta says um I'm I
uh okay option
Delta you know that's q and
uh and
uh uh uh
XA and and so I'm covering Q uh that
means
uh Q is no longer active and so I'm
going to move it I'm going to move it to
the end of this
list the the item list also
um uh keeps track of which light items
have I used in options and so I'm now
using Q um and
uh and and Q is no longer active uh uh
similar similarly X now when I see x a I
I go through all all of these things and
I
delete where X was not equal to a and
and
uh so I look at all the places where X
appeared 15 8 12 U 15 it was a that's
fine eight
um is a that's fine 12 is B so so so I
got to remove this so
um okay so so so this size goes down to
two and uh and also X becomes inactive
uh so so active goes down to three so so
so at this point I'm I'm
sitting after I've CH chosen Delta uh
you have you have to believe me because
because I understand this is going quick
but now the the active items now are 2
21 and 11 namely p uh Y and R and and
uh
uh and that's the sub problem with those
active items and then I've also reduced
uh all the all the options that that are
incompatible with what I've chosen um
uh and
so although I haven't really removed
anything from the set of Q uh it doesn't
matter Q is no longer active
uh so so left with a Sub sub problem
with with three items p r and and why
and and this table tells me exactly
what's uh uh what's that and and
uh so once I go to the sub problem I can
easily go back afterwards and if if I
say oh no let let me not go to that sub
let me do the other way uh and undoing
is extremely fast in this in this thing
okay so so so that's the
um uh that's the idea of Dan cells and
and and now I'm going to show you uh
uh performance you know that it actually
works but but is there a question before
yeah um what you pause that doesn't
change I do have my hearing a um so
pause does not
change I should have changed very
good you get highest priority yeah
um in fact um if you look
uh yeah okay yeah uh yeah yeah PES is
the inverse is the
in so so the position of Q uh went from
one to four and the position of
uh of
um
why went from four to one
yeah okay very
good you I have a question so uh I might
just not have understood this but I'm
more coming from the sub doain and you
said every xcc problem is equivalent to
S problem right so in s one of the
things that makes uh solving real
efficient please start
over so um in sving one of the things
that M solver is really efficient is uh
action conflict learning so you don't
have to explore all the branches because
you learn something from exploring one
of the branch so the undoing here seems
pretty cool uh how would you do
something like trying to learn which
branches you don't need to explore
anymore because you have already learned
information that makes them not
possible
uh so
that's okay so first I have the basic
algorithms for how to walk around and
navigate and then I can build I can I
can build all kind of other stuff you
know
uh all
theistic and like the learning and so on
in my xcc salvers however uh I haven't I
haven't gotten I haven't put learning in
yet uh and and still on the kinds of
problems that they're working on it
turns out that
uh you know it's it's not a win it's not
such a win as it is for sad salver but
but but I I I take other problems and I
can to set and and and and and you know
sometimes the learning is really
important and similarly we with with CSP
and and so on and there's also questions
of restarts and all kinds of other stuff
that goes on uh uh so so yeah we we're
dealing with with tough problems and and
so we we need lots of Tricks but but the
uh uh the the kind uh it turns out that
there's this class of problems that uh
uh
uh I sort of I I would always do with a
that solver and there are other problems
that I always do with my xcc solver and
and so far uh uh it's kind of an art to
to decide which which one is actually
going to work better when you get to the
really hard when you get to the really
hard
problem but but but speaking of problems
let me look at at at some benchmarks so
so um uh I
brought yeah
so right now I'm working on volume 4
C uh and the first part of volum for C
is going to be about
um U
CSP so so so volum 4B was sort of half
of it was xcc half of it was was set and
and fin for is is starting out with uh
constraint satisfaction so the I'm in
the middle of writing it and
um uh I've still got I'm hoping to
finish it by
Spring uh this part and and then it'll
be available online uh uh well right now
you you if if if you if you're clever
you can figure out how to look at the at
the current trap U I'll put a
link I I'll I'll put a link on but uh u
i i I wanted to show you
um some of the output some of the
results oh I see I
I whoops do we oh okay so um yeah this
is this is my hand copy I I I should
have taken okay anyway uh here we have
um
uh oh
aha uh page 63 of the current draft so
so I I I I set up
a a bunch of Benchmark problems that
that were typical and not too not too
easy and and so here's
a I don't want to go go to the details
exactly what
the what what they are but
but for example problem Q is is the
classical problem of
uh of of 16
Queens take a 16 X6 board and place one
Queen in every row and one in every
column no two in the same diagonal and U
there are 14 million solutions to this
you have 256 options
uh you know 16 by 16 uh places
uh you you you can put a queen
in in in row I and column J for you have
16 choices in each case and then you
have 32 primary options and 58 secondary
options the primary options are the rows
and columns and the secondary options
are the
diagonals um and and and so no uh
uh if we use if we use dancing links
um it turned out that uh it was it it
took
for 40 gamms that that's 40 billion
references to memory and dancing cells
44 gab so we didn't win that one um
however almost almost all the other
cases were doing rather well so here the
ratio was you know 80% of another Pro
problem that I added later D is 6 60% 66
so there's uh uh there was one uh which
was rather simple problem because it did
it didn't take very long to solve it all
where dancing links work better but
but in most of these uh you know dancing
cells was doing very very well
now uh then then we added
her istics you know better ways to
choose uh
uh and
this dancing cell turn out to to to make
that that simpler so so so we have other
ways to choose what we're going to use
for the next branch and after after we
bring in this the statistics on these
problems uh it turns out that that we
that we have three major uh uh her
istics one one is to use
the the most common one is the minimum
remaining values but then there's a
weighted heuristic which uh which in
this case give us a 20 fold speed up on
problem H problem H was an interesting
problem about
uh making snake paths with windmills I I
I I can't explain uh shortly but but but
anyway uh
and another trist that was invented two
or three years
ago called the failure rate statistic uh
in his case you know gave a big speed up
uh the problem of of
mcms and so
uh that was that was one of the one of
the nice things that uh uh
not now when when I combine
uh
sorry when I combine the
hers with uh and dancing
cells then I have
um
uh you know I I can do better on the
Queen's problem with the with the her so
dancing cells is starting to win uh
uh most of them
uh and that is
um okay that's half of my Benchmark but
I also but but I also have benchmarks
that that are much more difficult
problems uh for which I want to do more
extensive more extensive pruning more I
want to I I want to do do much better
look ahead uh uh to delete options that
uh
uh that couldn't be used and so and so
there's a uh the
general a general idea that that we that
we
uh that's important in CSP called domain
consistency uh which in the context of
xcc problems says that uh I I don't want
to I don't want to keep any option that
could cause some other item to become
wiped out and uh so uh because I have
dancing cells I was able to write uh a
much more complicated program that that
would do this
extra this extra extra
special
uh uh what do you call it pruning of of
possibility
um and and cut the search tree way down
now it's expensive to do all to do all
this all this thinking about how can I
cut it down so so on on S on most
problems uh that I was faced with it it
turned out that I didn't really want to
do this expensive test uh because even
if I had a large search tree I was going
through so fast on each part of the
search tree there was no point in in
trying to make the search tree smaller
uh in fact I spent six months trying to
find a good
problem where I needed uh the extra
where I was I was going to get back the
amount of extra computation in order in
order to keep the surch Tre small um
however
U eventually I I found a bunch of of
problems for which uh uh this domain DC
stands for domain consistency FC stands
for forward consist consistency which is
a weaker kind of of pruning and uh and
so
um because I had the dancing cells
technology I was able to write this much
more complicated program that would that
that would uh that would solve xcc
problems with with domain consistency
and this this meant that I that on a a
lot of these I could solve problems that
I never thought I could I never thought
I'd be able to solve so you look at
these numbers and
uh and I have a problem here
uh
that unfortunately time
is since since time is up up I can't I
can't go into into too many more details
uh but I do want to have one
more one more thing is that u x Beyond
xcc problems there's another class of
problems called m
MCC problems and and this is u a vast
generalization of
xcc so the MCC problem says that instead
of saying that every primary item has to
be covered exactly once you you give a
range and say every primary atom has to
be covered at least a times and at most
B
times uh and and this
uh opens up a lot large number of of
other problems and it's it's important
Global constraint that uh
uh know that that that
that so when I use daning links to solve
MCC problems I had to introduce a new
dance step uh and and it's it's
discussed uh uh and we solved a bunch of
them but but but now uh a friend of mine
in Belgium named Philip Stoppers
uh two months
ago showed me that you could use dancing
cells to solve the MCC problems and not
only the excc problem and and and so
here finally uh I've got some problems
these these problems have script letter
uh code names and and these are all MCC
MCC problems and with dancing links
compared to dancing cells and and and
three different uh her
istics we make make major
uh major improvements in
these in in most of these so so here
here for example I I was doing 200 uh
gigm and now it's down to 39 or 38 gigm
with dancing
soell
yeah uh so so people who who are want to
Pur through this further my programs are
are online uh so SSX cc is the program
that
solves uh this is sparse set xcc
solver uh
ssmcc is is the new one I just added
last month the the
sparse uh MCC solver and then there's
the xcc DC which is the xcc solver with
domain
consistency and uh these these programs
are I think state-of-the-art now and
they all use dancing
cells thank you for sticking with me
[Applause]
I'm